We've already seen how to change file
permissions using the chmod command.
But what if you need to change
a files group or owner?
There are also commands
that allow you to do that.
They are Chown.
C-H-O-W-N.
And change group.
C-H-G-R-P.
We'll play with this bash history file
here located on our home directory.
Its permissions are set so only
the owner can read and write the file.
This file stores a recent history of
every command the user has typed, so
it's for security reasons only that
the user can read and modify the file.
If you run cat on bash history,
you'll see that we can
currently read this file.
If we change the file's group to root
using this command sudo chgrp root and
then then name of the file.
If we try to cat this file again,
you'll see that we can still read it.
The group has no permissions on this
file, so there's pretty much no effect.
Our ability to read this file right now
is determined by the owner setting,
not the group setting.
But now, if we change the owner
to root of the bash history file,
you'll see that we can
no longer read the file.
Permission is denied, and this is
because only the owner can read and
write the file and that owner's root.
Our current user student would
fall in the everyone category and
they have no permission
at all to read this file.
Go ahead and change the owner and
the group back to student on this file.
We were just experimenting
to show these commands and
when you might need to use them.
Now let's move on to the last security
topic we'll discuss, firewalls.